hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to slip Aereo now I've
learned a few things about this game
including the ability to zoom out I
don't know if that's just because I Oh
mods which was a gharial mods but it's
now io mods because there's multiple i/o
games now but this is how I'm going to
play it a little bit better than I did
before
I'm going to be more aggressive I'm
going to be more oh please don't kill me
I think not I I need to be more
merciless as the problem so what what
I'm going to do is I'm diving directly
in this is the center of this pool and I
am going after people like it was my job
and also there's something about zooming
out it makes it look like the dots are
bigger they actually just like zoom out
a little bit more so they look bigger
too they're not worth any more but they
are just bigger so I need to that's what
I'm going to be doing and that's the
strategy that I'm going to be employing
in this entire time that I'm doing this
okay that wasn't my fault those lag
that wasn't me oh what a load of ass
well this is where I'm gonna be
embarrassing myself over and over again
the thing about knowing more about the
game is that I actually realize what
kind of dumb luck it actually was for me
to get to fourth place in the last game
in the first place because I was very
patient in the last game and what I'm
not now is patient I am very aggressive
I want everyone to die except for me and
I want success no matter the cost and
what that ends up with is a recipe for
disaster that's gonna end with me being
dead and everyone being better than me
oh well so sad for me it's still
nerve-wracking I will admit there's
something about these online multiplayer
games knowing that I'm playing up
against real people it always gets my
blood bow a little blowing always blows
my blood it always makes me feel a
little bit nervous about what I'm doing
because heck I'm performing now people
are watching what I'm doing and then
people are judging me for how bad I am
well I'm not that bad I'm pretty decent
I got to fourth place and even if I
don't do as good as that this time
around that all that matters is that I
tried my best because that's what
they've taught me in school there you go
oh geez oh man that guy lost out Oh got
you big fish haha oh man I swear it's
not doing what I'm controlling it to do
for my problems it's okay well haha got
you you were getting too aggressive a
little too greedy not quick enough on
the fly which is exactly the thing that
oh what a load of ass this is just
[ __ ] this is bad show all around for
everybody involved give me that I want
it I'm not big enough to get it I don't
deserve it I haven't earned it I haven't
gotten a blank I'm all short and
shriveled not nearly comparative to
everybody else
oh man that's embarrassing see I I like
I like to cry foul when things don't go
my way but in all honesty I understand
it's it's that is that is bizarre that
guy's just spawning out of the ether
he's kind of man he's too big too big ok
just I'm just gonna wait for someone
else to be sloppy like that cuz
everyone's gonna be fighting everybody
here oh god that guy the sloppiness
never hurt nobody
some people just spin in circles
whenever the threaten it's like a
defensive move they tuck into themselves
just orbit nothingness and hope that
everything goes away but that's not how
the world works sometimes you got a
rampaging Marc EMU coming down at ya
nobody likes that man it is just it is
just loping looping giant snakes
wherever you go it almost seems like a
magical world of fun and freedom except
it's not it's filled with murder and
death and just general bad feelings all
around and everyone wants to kill
everyone else and everyone wants to
stand on top of their corpses so that
their success can measure up to everyone
else's but in reality there's no there's
no proper measurement of success here
it's just constant never-ending battle
of supremacy that's never gonna be one
because everyone cycles into an ending
on an expired of death and despair oh
god why anyway I don't know how I'm
gonna be able to keep up with anybody on
the leaderboard everyone is just in this
server is just astronomically huge like
the guy in first place is literally
twice as big as the guy in second place
like how is it even possible oh this guy
he's got done goofed puppy could have
spiraled in there but it is decided yeah
whatever I guess it's not worth it
man it just doesn't seem like I'm
growing as fast as I have before because
I'm not coming across death there used
to be a lot more death in this around
here there used to be just non-stop
death wherever you go but now people are
wising up people understand the
methodology of the game in this short
span of time that's been out so I must
adapt as well use my brain powers but
that's a very unlikely solution wow that
guy narrowly avoided death oh no Ellis
died okay the guy in number one died is
no longer supreme maybe he just gave up
probably because I would have thought
that if he would have died then there
would have been just tons and tons and
tons of other people like just like
scooping up huge amounts of crap
everywhere you go
okay let's see you be smart enough to go
for that haha okay got him you don't get
to win off of other people's success I
get to win off of other people's success
so right now I'm in the very heart of
the universe and apparently I'm just
kind of what are you doing maybe maybe I
was someone that saw my name it was like
myself to you which has happened before
or at least I imagine that's what
happened because there's really no
explanation for the rampant suicide that
people are shoving themselves inside of
me this guy
oh yeah that's so sad oh well Wow okay
I'll take some of this this guy was very
good
okay we're number 45 on the map right
now that's not the best but it's doing
better than I was that is lag lag is not
good lag is my death if lag leads to
death I'm gonna rage quit I'm gonna
break my keyboard I'm gonna smash my
computer screen I'm gonna dump my
computer in hydrochloric acid it's gonna
be bad for everybody involved
oh that whoa hello buddy good thing he
went for that not for me because I
wasn't exactly paying attention I was
just imagining the ways that I'm gonna
destroy my computer by throwing it off a
cliff and then dumping it into a ravine
and then sending it to the bottom of the
ocean and then Fernan Lou oh [ __ ]
I wonder if this guy's really is he
really silly enough he's silly enough
well silly Billy silly Billy
got trapped
Oh
what you gonna do buddy what's gonna do
what's gonna do who what's gonna do
buddy what's he gonna do what's it gonna
do oh well looks like whoa hello I want
you I want you inside of me well this is
an awkward engagement but you know what
I have a funny feeling that it's gonna
end not in the way that you hope it will
unless somehow someway other that's
right that's the end for you it's a
little douchey definitely douchey and I
think that was another fan of mine that
thrusts himself his or her self run my
snake we're number 22 were almost on the
leaderboard so long as we can hold it
together then everything is gonna be
okay but you know me that don't happen I
do stupid things all the time
whoa okay big big fish big fish just
died nope mine mine mine
number 19 and I'll admit this is way
more difficult than it was before
there's a lot more going on there's a
lot more competition there's a lot more
people that are being like smart about
the way that they're doing these things
so I am very disturbed I mean it's small
change compared to what I have here but
I'll take it
oh man this lag is not favorable don't
do this to me lag oh god don't do this
to me Wow how did he get that guy that
doesn't make any sense at all wow that
didn't make any sense I don't know how
that happened but it was stupid on the
other guy's part whoa a lot of big fish
just died and I don't know how or why
I'm just gonna swoop in get what I can
and get out No Oh what no what no it was
not what happened
goddamn it lag lag lag lag lag lag lag
lag
Lag I'm gonna I guess I got a dump my
computer in boiling oil now I gotta
shove it in my butt cheeks and squeeze
so hard until it turns into a diamond I
gotta light it on fire then put it out
with more gasoline I gotta throw it off
the top of a plane while it's flying
into a black hole I gotta chuck it into
a basin of rabid weasels that are gonna
chew it to bits I've got to punch it
with my fists and my ass my ass fists
until it explodes I've got it [ __ ]
either way I'm gonna break my computer
now because they didn't do very good but
anyway that is slow very oh thank you
everybody so much for watching in the
next video I'm gonna start a party with
you guys and then you are gonna be the
one to blame for me being dead sound
good sounds good so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
because I can't handle this
could I go into Shrek swap come by about
just 420 blaze it with Shrek